hey there everybody for this last  video for pride month i wanted to  bring up the q in lgbtqia plus one more  time  now when i originally defined those  terms i said it stood for queer and it  does but it can also stand for  questioning it's okay  to not be sure of where you fall  in terms of your gender it's okay to  explore  things without being certain that a  label is going to fit you ultimately  and it's okay if you explore these  things  that you ultimately realize no  i actually am straight  or cisgender and you go back to using  those identifiers  because some people still need to go on  a journey  to find comfort in where they started  it's all valid  and you are too